joining me now who will not be singing
but i think he gets the message the
president of the heritage foundation
kevin roberts kevin i could not believe
that statement and it was intentional
almost poll tested
would you be surprised if 70 million
people were insulted by it oh
being one of those 70 million i can tell
you that we're insulted and look we've
gone from one of the most successful
presidencies in history just objectively
brian doesn't matter where someone is on
the political spectrum to the worst
presidency in less than a year and a
half and so i can tell you that people
are insulted they're infuriated by the
hyperbole and they're frankly looking
for president biden to actually be
halfway competent
the other big story
which will remain a big story until we
find out the actual verdict probably at
the end of june will be the impact of
overturning roe v wade uh and the
protests that are happening across this
country especially around the homes of
the supreme court justices which i
personally find totally unacceptable i
said the same thing if pro-lifers were
going after uh liberals in some way
shape or form but what impact will that
have on the midterms with the what you
see at the heritage
well let me just hang on your first
point real briefly and say it's
unconscionable that president biden did
not condemn the the proposed violence at
the homes of these supreme court
justices like you i would agree as all
pro-lifers would that shouldn't happen
to any member of the court even if they
disagree with us on pro-life issues but
to your question i think the the
electoral impact of this ultimately is
going to be a little more helpful to the
right than to the left i know that our
radical leftist friends believe that
this is going to drive turnout but what
we're seeing qualitatively and
quantitatively at heritage that is
looking at two or three polls this week
is that americans realize the agenda on
the left regarding abortion isn't merely
protecting roe versus wade it's actually
allowing partial birth abortions there's
a bill that's been filed in the
california assembly to that point brian
that would allow abortions quote unquote
abortions up to a week after the baby
has been born the more our side can
focus on that i actually think the more
this is a net positive electorally for
conservatives and also it's it's not
banning abortion it's uh letting the
states decide and then you can decide
where you live like you decide about
taxes like you decide about
freedom when it comes to mass and
everything else let's move to the last
element within the republican party
you know all these players it seems like
there seems to be a growing rift between
the bushes and the trumps and i'll give
you an example
for example george w bush is now going
out for brian kemp
and
strong for brian kemp in georgia as
opposed to purdue for trump of course
liz cheney is being primaried in wyoming
chinese and bushes are tight and trump
couldn't have more of a rift with cheney
and then you have a situation where
george p bush is running for attorney
general against ken paxton they're on
opposite sides does that concern you as
somebody who's a conservative well it
concerns me that there's a rift in our
movement because we've got to get busy
about the business of taking back this
country what i will say and be careful
not to sound like i'm making an
endorsement because that's not the
business i'm in is that when it comes to
the conservative movement brian that
where this movement is going if you look
at jd vance's win in ohio this week is
toward a working-class conservatism that
is hostile to the centralized power in
dc to the establishment they want
politicians who actually do what they
say they were going to do when they're
on the campaign trail that's the
business heritage is in you know the
different tribes in the party are going
to win some and lose some ultimately
we're focused on a conservative
governing majority that does the
business of the people which is taking
back this country last question real
quick you're stiff farming big business
going to blue collar does that concern
you reagan embraced big business
well it doesn't concern me although i
love your question and you're right that
reagan did embrace big business you know
why because 40 years ago when he did so
big business loved america right now we
have fortune 10 companies who say like
the big tech companies they're not even
american companies so i'm happy to stiff
arm anybody who hates this country and
embrace the small guys because it's
ultimately the small guys who make this
country what it is kevin roberts
heritage foundation thanks so much kevin
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else